let's go to our next caller from the
four for three area code who's calling
today from four four three
hey David this is Jack hey Jack
yes again I was just wondering if you've
ever heard Ari Shaffir you know who are
with Ari Shaffir no I'm not okay you've
been on the Jill Rogan show before right
yes correct
and what's your Rogen's friend yeah he
I'm wondering if you've ever heard his
argument on abortion before well I might
have heard the argument without knowing
he was making it what's what's his
argument that it is murder but that it's
murder for convenience and that like
it's okay basically how do you feel
about that I'd have to hear how he
defends it I mean listen I I think I
don't know how you say that abortion is
murder in the abstract sense you know a
lot of times the debate becomes is
abortion destroying life and then you'll
sometimes hear people get into these
semantics back and forth about well it's
it's the potential for life versus is
actual its actual life I think the more
relevant question is not is it life
because so many things on this planet
are forms of life in some way under the
broadest definition the question is are
we talking about a person when we're
talking about an abortion early on in
the pregnancy and I've seen no solid
scientific argument that that is a
person and so that's more my guiding
principle I guess I'd have to hear this
guy's our argument but to really
understand it no III agree with you but
I just think it's interesting me the
point of like and I think what he's
trying to get at is that it is a life
eternally there is the middle ground
that I I do think that conservatives
don't see like oh it is a woman's body
like like they don't they don't believe
that it's a woman spot what does that
mean no they don't believe that it's a
woman's right to like they believe it's
a woman's woman's body but they don't
believe that it's a woman's right to
like choose whether or not that life
exists or not in other words then one
other
someone they want someone other than the
woman who is carrying the potential for
life to make a decision about what the
woman can do correct yeah
I'm again sometimes yeah I am too and
sometimes like liberals don't want to
see like oh well at at a certain point
if you like continue to let this
life-form exist it would become a guy
named Steve on the street sure that that
would happen well they use that very and
there is that exactly right and so I
think the the the I know people some
people hate it when I make this analogy
but a lot of time this is the problem
with simply coming up with a set of
quote principles and then believing that
the hard work is the principles rather
than their application when the
application is really where most of the
thinking has to take place and I know
people don't like this analogy but it's
like with a speed limit when we say that
the speed limit on a road is thirty-five
that doesn't mean forty might not be
safe when it's nice out that doesn't
mean that you don't have to slow down to
25 when it's icy out you at some point
have to figure out okay here is our
principle for how we set speed limits
and we're gonna pick a number and I know
it's a crude analogy to abortion but at
a certain point the fact that you can't
say with 100% consensus this is the day
at which it is now a person doesn't mean
the solution is abortion is illegal that
makes perfect sense and I agree with you
completely alright yeah thank you for
the call appreciate it great to hear
from you